hello i'm brianna and in this video i'm
going to go over a lot of things having
to do with bash mostly the basics we're
going to start off um really basic like
what is bash what is that you know how
do i even get around
all the way through configuration using
different types of scripts with bash so
hopefully at the end you'll feel a
little bit more comfortable working in
the terminal
so starting off as you can see
bash is a terminal it is the terminal
used on mac and linux by default so it's
a little bit different than powershell
when people say terminal it could mean a
lot of different things it could mean
bash it could mean
something like zsh shell which is kind
of similar
or powershell but this is all about bash
so
we open up bash i opened up my terminal
application
in um on my mac computer
and the very first thing that i want to
type so it's kind of intimidating if
you've never been here before
but i want to just do echo and then i'm
dollar sign zero so echo space dollar
sign zero
this i click enter return
this says bash so this is just
confirming that i am in bash so find
your terminal type echo space dollar
sign zero if it says bash then you're in
the right spot whatever i type today
should work for you as well unless you
have some different configurations set
up
so we're here we don't know what here is
other than
bash so i'm going to type pwd so pwd
stands for print working directory and
that just means it's going to print out
wherever i currently am so currently i'm
in my computer's users directory
and then github teacher so that's the
user that i'm logged into right now
i can use pwd at any time to know where
i am which is pretty helpful
the next command i want to show is
called ls
so ls is going to list whatever's in my
current directory if there's any files
or other directories
so here i see i have applications
documents library what you'd expect we
also have ls space-a-l
let's see if there's any hidden files
here and it also gives us some more
information
we see all these letters on the left
we'll talk about those later
owner of the file their permission level
and then here the dot in front of a file
means it's a hidden file so when i just
did ls i wasn't able to see those files
like dot trash dot adam dot bash history
which we'll talk about soon
so know that ls and ls-al are there so
that
you can see what's going on in the
directory that you're currently in
when i list my files and directories i
see documents downloads all these things
i want to make a new folder a new
directory called projects so i'm going
to do
mkdir for make directory
and then space and then projects i do a
capital p here
so i type mkdir projects hit enter it
tells me nothing
but if i do ls i can see now i have
a projects directory that i didn't have
before
so i just created an empty file that's
it
using mkdir
so i've made this directory but i'm not
currently in it right if i do pwd i'm
still in my github teacher directory so
to change directories i'll do cd
projects
cd space projects
what what you see on the left hand side
changes a little bit that'll depend on
what configurations what you know
that can look different from computer to
computer especially with developers that
have been using bash for a while
if i do pwd now
it's a little different so before i was
just in github teacher now i'm in github
teacher slash project so i created the
directory and then
changed directory into it
if i do ls here
we see nothing else al i just see these
dots which means i can go back so we've
changed directory into a directory but
like maybe i want to go back let's say i
want to go back to being in this
github teacher directory i can type
come back terminal i'll type cd space
dot dot
now if i do pwd i'm back in github
teacher
no big deal
we've created a directory it's good to
know how to get rid of a directory just
in case so if you need to delete a
directory you can do rmdir so mkdir to
create
rmdir and then i'll do projects so when
i just created i'm just going to scrap
it
now if i do ls oops
not ld if i do ls
then projects is no longer there
even if i do lsal al it's not there
anymore
i'll go ahead and recreate that
mkdir projects just so that we have
something to we're going to keep making
some changes um
but now you've seen a lot of the basics
we know how to navigate around we know
where we are with pwd
we can
change directories with cd both forwards
and backwards um list the files in any
given directory make directories delete
directories it's already a lot right
with just a few really basic commands
hopefully by now you already are
figuring out there's nothing to be
afraid of when you're when you're in the
terminal
let's talk a little bit about working
with files we've talked about
directories let's work with files
all files are case sensitive with bash
this is important to consider as you
might be working with something another
program like you're working with git the
way
git or any program fi
handles case sensitivity might be
different than how bash handles case
sensitivity so keep in mind bash is case
sensitive
let's cd into that project change
directories into projects and i'm going
to make a new file because we do ls
because there's nothing
to create a new empty file i'm just
going to type touch
i'll call it file1.md
for markdown the file format that i use
a lot
press return and it tells me nothing if
i do ls
now i see i have this file1.md if i do
ls-a-l
i've still got those dot files with
file1.md see who it's owned by and the
letters are a little different but we'll
get there
creating a file pretty easy
to delete that file rm
just rmfile1.md
now it's no longer there
some different ways we can manipulate
files let's go ahead and make this file
again we'll call it file 2.md
i've created this file
let's say i want to copy this file so i
want to make a duplicate
i'm going to type cp
file2.md and then the name that i want
the new copy to have so i'm going to
call this file2copy.md
as soon as i do that if i do ls i see
i've got these two files here
they're empty they're both empty but if
file two had some contents in it that
would now be mapped exactly to file to
copy
you can also rename files just really
simply so if i do mv
let's say i want file to copy this new
file
i want that to just be called file three
so i'll do mv file to copy dot md the
old name and then the new name i'm gonna
call file three
if i do lsal
file two copies now i'll bend rename to
file three pretty straightforward
so far since we've started working with
files we've used touch
rm
mv and cp so touch creates a file
rm removes it cp copies it and creates
another one and
mv just renames it or moves it to a
different file name
we also have cat for concatenate
concatenate
so this is a way to create single or
multiple files you can view the contents
of a file you can link files together so
view multiple files
redirect output in terminal files
there's a lot you can do with cat since
these two files are empty right now um
let's put some let's put some things in
there so let's do that with vi
so vi is kind of a different level so
bash and terminal can already be
intimidating uh
vi i would say is another level vi is
always a text editor within the terminal
uh you might hear people also v vim them
in vi are different um i don't use
either one regularly so i'm sure there
are a lot of people out there who can go
into a lot more detail than i can but
it's important to know a little bit
about vi
you might end up in vi by accident and
it doesn't behave
necessarily how you'd think so
let's let's use it
to use vi let's add some contents to
file too so i'm going to type vi space
file2.md it's going to open up file2 in
vi so already it looks very different
um
if i tried to just type anything it
might not work once you're in vi mode to
actually insert
uh you press i or j so there's two two
modes of vi there's insert and command
so i'm gonna type a i hit i on my
keyboard and now we can see at the
bottom it says insert now i'm able to
type so i'm going to say file 2 is the
best file in the entire directory
so i've made my changes
now what do i want to do right how do i
get out if i press enter it just goes
down getting i think that's like how do
i get out of vi is the most pop or most
asked question on stack overflow
so here we are how do we get out of vi
first we need to get into that command
mode right so i'm going to press escape
we see the insert is gone at the bottom
i'm going to
shift so it's colon and now we can see
that at the bottom that's putting us
into command
mode
w for right because i want to save these
changes and queue for quit i could just
do q and it wouldn't save but wq will
save
and quit
hit enter
so that's it i'm out of vi
let's do that again
let's do it for file three so i'm going
to open vi file3.nd
first thing i do is
type i to begin insert mode
start typing file3 is a pretty good file
too
now my instinct as somebody who uses the
computer is to do command s or ctrl s to
save but that will not work in vi the
same way it'll work in other programs
to get out of this i'm going to hit
escape to get out of insert mode
colon
wq and enter
we're done
so we've kind of done these basics of a
vi uh just the need to know basics of
how to get out and how to get in how to
make some changes
let's use that cat um command so you're
gonna do cat file two dot nd
and it prints out just the contents of
file two that i just put in there
i can do cat file two dynamd file3.md so
i'm doing two different files and it
prints out both
both of the contents the contents for
both of the files
so so far we've done a lot right we've
worked with directories how to get
around if i do pwd the first thing we
really talked about i'm still in my
projects directory ls i still have these
two files here file two and file three
let's talk a little bit about how to
configure your bash shell so what that
means is right now my bash is pretty
monotone there's just white and black
um
if you're ever if you ever see somebody
else working in a terminal whether it's
on a video or in person you know sitting
next to somebody on an airplane
their terminal might not look like this
it probably doesn't look like this
i configure mine to um
have some
different colors that make it easier for
me to read which is you know the most
basic probably way to do it but you can
configure your bash terminal for a lot
of different things so you can include
aliases so that i you only have to type
something small but i actually will run
a much longer script or command
you can configure
authentication tokens
for different services like git
and github
let's start out with the colors
so for the colors
the first thing we're going to look for
is this dot bash profile and dot bash rc
so again pwd i'm in projects i need a cd
back into my main user directory and i'm
going to do ls al
so i see i have
bash history and bash sessions but since
i haven't used
the bash rc or bash profile file yet
they're not on this user they're not in
this user account
if those files exist or not by default
will depend on your operating system
so linux you probably already have those
mac you might not that's okay
we're just going to create it
so we know how to create files touch
dot
bash rc
and touch dot bash underscore profile
bash profile is executed for login
shells and bashrc is executed for
interactive non-login shells meaning
bash profile is going to have those
authentication tokens that we talked
about whereas bashrc is going to have
more just general
general configurations in it
okay so i'm going to open up that bash
rc i'm not going to do it in vim i'm
actually going to use my favorite text
editor which is adam
um and to do that i'm going to go to
atom
there is a way to configure atom so it's
a used atom space in the file name i
haven't done that let's see if it'll
work just by default adam space dot oh
great so adam space anything will open
up that specific file dot in bash like i
just did means current directory
so let's open the current directory so
everything i see on the left hand side
here
is the same i would see an ls ls-a-l
i'm gonna open up this bash rc file in
atom
and i'm gonna copy this which i'll
put in the video description here
here
oh
actually no i'm not gonna put that in
the bash profile so what this does is
this is making sure that we only are
sourcing
the bash rc from the bash profile
um if bash doesn't know where to look it
might not behave how you'd expect it to
you might get some different errors and
bugs so this is making sure that
the batch profile is always looking for
the bash rc to make sure it's taking
whatever configurations are there into
account also
so i'll save that change in my bash
profile
now when i log into any machine
from a console this bash rc is
automatically going to be called
let's go ahead and configure some colors
let me pull up these
different colors here
this is what i'm looking at so i'll put
a link to this little gist of code so
it's a little bit different if depending
on your operating system since i'm on a
mac i'm going to add this to the bash
profile so here's this script so this is
going to be affecting my get output
specifically so you could do that or
this one here
so this is specifically for
for git
copied one i'll put that in bash profile
i'll put this this um hash sign i'm
putting here is a comment
uh colors for get output
and i'll paste that in and save
and i also want to
so this is something i got from a
friend
i'll save that give her that and then
back in the best bash rc let's try
colors for other text
let's try this
now here let's open up terminal again
there we go okay so
cli color 1 enables coloring of your
terminal and then the ls colors
specifies how to color specific items
okay
there we go
so there's a lot of different ways you
can
you know
customize this so that the output is
much different
here we do pwd it's still black ls-a-l
here we see how
you know certain things look
look different based on if they're a
directory or if they are just a file
customizing your your prompt and
configuring things goes a lot deeper
than this you can what you can do is is
absolutely massive but the most
important thing to know is that you find
those customizations in your dot bash rc
and your dot bash profile
okay
let's move on to something else
let's talk about the internet so i'm
going to type clear
here clear is just a terminal a
shell bash command to literally clear
off everything that's on the terminal so
that you have a fresh start clear all
right
so you can interact with the internet
and other networks from bash that means
you know whatever program you're using
can interact with the internet
you'd usually want to do this to check
the network connectivity or speed so if
i type ping google.com
that tells me
how fast my internet connection is
really quickly
i'm going to press ctrl hold it down and
then click c to exit that so if you're
ever stuck in a mode it's either vi mode
right and then you would do
escape colon wq or something like this
where there's an operation running a
system task then i would do control and
c to exit that
um so interacting with the internet a
lot of different cli tools will access
the internet git is a great example of
this
so i'd have my remote repository on
github.com my local repository on my
computer i can interact with that
entirely from bash and that will be done
via the internet so just remember
anything that you do
um
in the shell right you
are not automatically just on your own
computer
which is a great thing but also good to
know in case you might be making changes
to something
let's move on to what else can you do
from bash uh so we've
done quite a bit already right we've
created files we've navigated around we
know how to get out of v and get in or
get out of vi and get into the eye
let's talk about how to
do some more advanced things mostly
scripts
so as an example
i would like to show you
this script and we're gonna create it
we're gonna run it we're gonna make it
work
so this script here
this example is what i used before i
teach class that i was talking about it
quits certain applications it hides my
doc because i really don't want slack
notifications coming up while i'm
teaching a class
and it opens certain applications so
mouse pose and moom which are things i
used to show my mouse and move windows
around make sure those are open
make sure certain browsers are open and
even triggers other scripts like the
teach class script
one that we're going to create is really
simple
so here we see the top line is
this pound sign exclamation bin bash
that just tells bash that this file is
actually a bash script so i'm going to
go ahead and go back to bash here i'm
going to cd out of this repository so
i'm back in projects you can see that
here
i'm going to
let's take a look at this script okay so
it's just a good morning world so i'm
going to touch good morning
so i just created a file called good
morning
and i'm going to vi good morning
so now i'm in vi okay
next let's insert if i type i so that
we're in insert mode
and at the top is that pound exclamation
bin slash
exclamation slash bin slash bash
enter
clear i'm going to just clear the prompt
right like you could do as any
standalone command and echo which we
haven't talked about yet echo just has
the
terminal has a bash print out exactly
what's in quotes so echo good
good morning world
will then have the terminal print that
out echo is a really really useful
command when you're working with shell
scripts because frequently through your
script you might want to know you know
like a console log kind of thing you
know what's going on i want to have this
as feedback this message will print out
at a certain time during my script
so that's good looks good
i hit escape colon wq and exit
now let's see the moment of truth
we've created this script if i just type
good morning let's see what we expect
it says command not found
let's talk a little bit about
all these letters at the beginning so
back in
the terminal here if i do ls-al we see
at the beginning of these files
all these drw xr you know slash
those are impacting our ability to run
that script as a command
so
chmod and file folder permissions so
this first
blank indicates the file type whether
it's a directory with a d or just a
regular file
from then we have these three other
groups
one for the owner members of the group
and all other users so that means any
given file might have different
permissions
for other people on the computer you
know as an owner i might be able to do
something but then if somebody else
logged into the machine they would only
be able to you know read that file they
couldn't execute whatever that script
was
so what you want to do if we take a look
at our newly created script which is
called good morning
nowhere is it executable we have r
read access w write access for the owner
so i'm allowed to make edits no one else
can make edits even
but we want to have x
i'm not so concerned of if other users
have any access to this file i just want
to have access right now
so what i'm going to do is type chmod
plus
x and then the file name
so if i do ls-a-l now i see good morning
has
this x next to it now it's red because
it's an executable script instead of
just good morning we're gonna do
dots you know periods
slash good morning
and it cleared the terminal and did good
morning world so earlier it wasn't
working because i was just typing good
morning
and remember when we're navigating
throughout the terminal it
is relative and it matters where we are
so it didn't know exactly where to look
for good morning here but when we do
dot slash meaning go back directory and
then look this slash then good morning
our current directory and slash
then we're in good shape then it knows
exactly where to look so
obviously this is a very simple script
example but that's how easy it is
anything that you run in
in any command can be put inside of a
shell script whether it's basic shell
you know language things or
api calls or other programs
so
a lot to know here there's a lot to to
be done and
thank you hopefully you feel better
about using bash hopefully you feel like
you can
um not be so afraid of using your
terminal